Ну і як просувається навчальний процес і
де він ускладнений поговоримо із Сергієм
шкарлетом міністром освіти і науки
України пане міністр Вітаю вас
вітаю вас Доброго дня Слава Україні
Героям слава підготовка до навчального
року була ускладнена війною перший
тиждень уже позаду чи всі школи
стартували які проблеми відкрилися із
початком навчання Ну і що зараз
залишається найбільшою проблемою
я вам дякую перш за все за увагу до
освіти адже це про майбутнє це про
виховання це про створення нових
перспектив нашої держави хочу сказати що
в нас
12904 школи розпочали освітній процес
Зараз на жаль
1289 шкіл перебувають на тимчасово
окупованій території і в цілому по
статистиці 3116 шкіл
розпочали формат навчання в віч-на-віч
повноформатному освітньому процесі 5713
виключно в форматі онлайн освіти і 4 075
шкіл розпочали освітній процес у
змішаному навчанні На жаль
враховуючи арт обстріли враховуючи ту
збройну агресію нашого північного сусіда
в нас є деякі рухи по зміні з першого по
11 вересня щодо формату о
424 школи наприклад перейшли в рамках
прямого обстрілу артилерії з очного на
дистанційне навчання але при цьому 44 48
шкіл Одеської області 44 хвилини
івано-франківської області повністю
перейшли формат очного навчання
це він він абсолютно зрозумілий під час
війни
і як дуже розумно ведуть освітні в
політику на сьогодні дякую вам
половина що щонайменше половина Минулого
року залишила відбиток на шкільній
освіті Ми пам'ятаємо що спочатку ковід і
потім війна чи довелося змінювати
програму задля того щоб наздогнати
втрачене
ви знаєте ковідна багато в чому навчив
робити дистанційну освіту більш якісною
після першого року ковіду ми разом з
державної служби якості освіти здійснили
моніторинг залишкових знань нашої учнів
і студентів і втім переобладнали взагалі
і переформатували систему і
всеукраїнської школи онлайн де зробили
можливість формувати безпосередній
прямий кабінет вчителя і учня а-а
розробляти власну освітню траєкторію
повертатись до невичених завдань робити
певні тестування щодо моніторингу якості
залишкових знань на сьогодні ми готові
до всіх викликів не тільки ковіду а й
війни і в цьому контексті
я просив кожного з нашого кожного з
наших вчителів певним чином
промоніторити в перші два тижні
освітнього початку освітнього процесу
наявність залишкових знань і матеріалом
і при необхідності в рамках шкільної
програми в рамках університетської
програми цей це є абсолютно нормальним
явищем коли ми повертаємось до вивчення
попередніх тем в нас доганяємо і
надолужуємо ті результати Якими маємо
запровадити для наших учнів і студентів
і рухаємось далі ми всі впевнено
дивимось перспективу Дуже дякую вам
Якщо говорити про перспективу то от ви
згадали що зараз
переглянули онлайн-освіту і якість і так
далі чи це означатиме що уже колись у
мирні часи які як ми сподіваємося що
пізно наступлять на стануть і це буде
перемога України а це означатиме що та
програма вже для Мирного часу теж зазнає
змін можливо учні отримують більше
можливостей навчання онлайн за бажанням
а ви розумієте про що якщо Той досвід
котрий ми зараз з винесемо з цієї
кризової ситуації що тут скажімо прямо
що він вплине на наступні на майбутні
форми навчання як вважаєте
Дуже дякую за запитання надзвичайно
актуально Дякую вам за професійність
адже в цьому контексті і на сьогодні ми
коли організовували освітній процес З 1
вересня і далі рухаємося в цьому форматі
ми чітко розуміємо що є дві умови
достатньою умовою є перш за все
наявність укриттів і безпечного
середовища в школі в закладі освіти в
іншому профтеху освіти коледжу
університеті в дитячому садочку А
необхідною умовою є або вибір батьків
або вибір всіх учасників освітнього
процесу і в цьому контексті вже на
сьогодні
основним основним акцентом
запровадження освітнього процесу є саме
вибір учасника довіри безпекової
ситуації Довіра у світі онлайн або
повноформа і на сьогодні всі заклади
освіти України сповідують цю взагалі то
цей наратив який ми для себе обрав
то зараз Багато дітей навчаються у
школах за кордоном і ми вже з вами про
це говорили можливо місяць тому
наскільки відрізняється система освіти
зокрема в Європі і чи є Ну якщо не
комунікація то принаймні якісь обмін
інформацією про адаптацію наших школярів
до навчання в інших країнах Ну і головне
як повернути їх тобто наших громадян
потім в українській освітній процес і
контекст
Дуже дякую за запитання
починаючи з 24 лютого коли розпочалась
повномасштабна агресія я мав щоденні
зустрічі
іноді з усіма міністрами освіти
Європейського Союзу і інших країн світу
іноді по черзі по декілька зустрічей
кожного дня для того щоб ті діти ті
студенти які вимушено потрапили на
територію інших країн світу були
долучені до освітнього процесу ми на
сьогодні маємо повну інтеграцію нашої
дітей в освітній процес але при цьому не
просто в освітній процес інших країн ми
сьогодні маємо від трьох до п'яти годин
щотижнево щодо вивчення української мови
української культури історія України
всіх тих необхідних
меседжів українських які є в українській
освіті в українській програмі для того
забували про українські стандарти освіти
ми сьогодні маємо на якщо немає трьох
п'яти годин щотижнева ми маємо суботню
школу на сьогодні ми повністю
ВКонтакті з усіма країнами Європейського
Союзу і провідними країнами світу щодо
щодо навчання наших дітей в тому числі і
долучені їх паралельного навчання за
українськими стандартами по міжнародній
українській школі це наша наша державна
установа яка сповідує українську освіту
в 36 країнах світу це ще наші 16
партнерів які сповідують дистанційну
освіту в цьому світі незалежно де дитина
перебуває і надають можливість працювати
в рамках освітніх стандартів України а
щодо повернення знаєте маю стриманий
оптимізм якщо навіть на
березня в нас було 670 тисяч дітей
шкільного віку які вимушено покинули
територію України то вже на наприклад на
1 вересня їх було
492 тисячі А на сьогодні за 11 за 11
днів
вже
488 000 шкільного віку залишилося
Так 4 000 дітей тільки за 11 днів
повернулись це
730 але але так але абсолютно турфір
Довіра збройним силам Довіра абсолютно я
я дуже вас прошу Це дуже цікава розмова
але мені підказують що часу вже не
залишається в нас тут випуск новин Я вам
дуже дякую за розмову Це був ваш час він
цінний і за вашу роботу тому що освіта -
це як правильно ви сказали це про
майбутнє і це надважливо Дякую вам це
був Сергій шкарлет міністр освіти та
науки України у нас на зв'язку